they're heading is probability trees and
I've got this multi-part question for
you it's from an HSC and it's a good
illustration of why probability trees
can be useful because we looked at tree
diagrams before they're very simple
objects oops but the particular thing
about them is that tree diagrams as
we've looked at them so far and we've
you know looked at in you know two ten
as well may cover events that are all
equally likely all equally likely which
is why if for example we looked at
flipping a coin three times in a row
that gives you three possible sorry
eight possible outcomes at the end and
each one is equally likely so it's um
one out of eight would be the chance for
each one but we use probability trees
where we say actually these two are not
the same maybe one event is more likely
than another hey guys where if you come
from grammar Satan pair up
so as this question unfolds you'll see
why this is a perfect example of when a
probability tree is useful so we've got
patterns how they play a game they take
turns throwing two dice okay so it's Pat
throws two dice then it's gonna be tries
to and he throws two dice etc okay the
game is won by the first player who
throws a pair of sixes at the same time
right
Pat starts the game so this is a simple
set up to each take their turns but even
though it's remarkably simple there are
some bits of it that are a bit of a
curveball so let's start by answering
the simple one right find the
probability that Pat wins on his first
throw so Pat does start the game so what
condition does he need to meet to win
two sixes okay so I'm going to say
probability of two sixes what is that
equal to we've this is a common
situation pair of sixes there are I mean
I could actually draw a large one of
these right with six branches the first
time and then six branches off each of
those branches but that's a bit of a
waste of time they're all equally likely
only one of those is a pair of sixes do
you agree with that there's only one way
to get that
so one is the favorable outcomes and the
total sample space will be how many how
many different options were they for the
two it's 36 right six times six and you
could draw a dot diagram would also do
that quite easily but there's nothing
complicated about this so we don't need
to we don't need to invest that time to
understand and get the question so
there's a probably that Patt words on
his first thorough Part B and he's where
the probability tree is going to come in
what's the probably the Pat wins the
game on his first or his second throw I
can a pause for a minute remember in
probability as in say you know like
trigonometry and that kind of things
sometimes a single word makes a big
difference I want you to have a look
here and I want you to tell me are we
doing in the end addition or
multiplication with our probabilities
and how do you know which one anyone
throw throw an answer come on or where
you reckon addition why do you say
addition its head again it says or first
or second throw so first throw will have
its probability we actually just work
that out okay second row will also have
its probability the or indicates you're
going to add those two together okay
so I'm going to write probability Pat
wins first or second okay so I know I'm
going to be adding two things together
so it's the first thing that's in my
mind I've already worked out his
probability of winning on the first row
that's one on 36 that was part a so now
I've got to work out this other bit and
here is where the probability tree comes
in for Pat o in on his second throw what
must happen what series events has have
to unfold well can he win on his first
throw and then progressed to the second
run no cuz the game is over already
right so that means when we think about
our branches here right I could say like
1 2 3 4 5 6 etc but I don't need to
worry about that I just need to think
about whether he wins or whether he
loses on that first throw these are the
two events that I'm really interested in
right if this is 1 out of 36 this other
event we haven't talked about this much
formally about her
when you remember it from earlier on
this other event here it's got a special
name starts with a C it's the continent
very good so this is a complementary
event which means that the two
probabilities for an event and its
complement what do they add up to bad up
to one so can you tell me what's the
probability that he doesn't win on that
first throw 35 and 36 okay
so we've already thought about what
happens if you win so I'm just going to
tick that off it's dealt with them but I
want to get to him winning on the second
throw so first he has to lose what's the
next event that happens have a think Pat
just had a roll right whose turn is it
now it's chat because they take their
turns
look where does it say there it's in the
first sentence right so 2/3 away long
they take turns throwing two dice so now
the next branch has nothing to do with
Pat its Chad wins or loses you okay with
this now this is a little bit weird
we're used to every branch always
continuing off on to the end but clearly
we've just said if he wins first time
the game is over
so the branches are not going to
continue up here okay I'm gonna pause
for a minute I haven't finished the
solution but I wonder if you can finish
the rest of this diagram put all the
information on there and then work out
what's your total probability gonna be
can we give me a couple minutes to have
a think off you go a lot of you have
headed down the right track quite
literally in fact we all agreed on this
one out of 36 it represents the
probability of Pat winning first go
good for you Pat but it is highly likely
that he does not write so summary sure
everyone's on the same page you got
Erika you're happy yes great now in
order for Pat to win not on his first
but on his second throw we actually have
to do it if you've got other colors here
you might as well use them right you've
got to follow the chain of events that
leads to that happening first to win on
the second round he has to lose then
Chad also has to lose otherwise the game
is over and then suddenly here that's
when he gets his second opportunity to
win so you can see
if I look at the branches yeah this is
where in fact there's a bit of a trick
question that I threw out to you and the
thinner ax correctly answered
nonetheless which is that are you adding
or you multiply and the answer is yes
because you have to add these two
separate events but in order to get to
this one you you have to multiply along
because you're reading from left to
right across the probability tree do you
remember we talked about this before now
I'm going to put this second probability
I'm gonna put it in brackets here now we
know our order of operations well enough
to know that I don't need to put the
brackets here to indicate the correct
answer but I like to put the brackets
there to sort of communicate to you
he's one event here's a completely
separate one it's more from my brain
than anything else and then to
communicate that to others now if I've
read this correctly you're gonna get
some awkward fraction on here right some
two thousand on 40 what is it forty six
four six six five eight is that right
five six yeah that sounded better okay
great now part of the problem is this
does that look right I don't know right
it's it's hard to get a like oh I know
my 46,656
really well and that gives me a great
sense of it but we can at least know if
you for example converted both of these
guys into decimals okay in fact let's do
that can we can you tell me oh great
that's thank you
uh what do we got here zero point zero
zero point zero five four four dot dot
dot what someone got 136 who's got it I
just want a decimal value for zero point
zero two seven
hey don'tdon't Oh doc I can't you just
have a look at this right from here to
here the chance has increased does that
make sense
should it increase yes it should because
you're considering the first or the
second you're just adding them together
it'll better get bigger it's almost
double its all this double Wow really
why do you think that might be
well have a look at these conditions
here these ones here would you describe
them as unlikely or likely but those are
highly likely like they're like 90 97
percent chance that one of these is
going to happen so these are almost
certain and then this event here is just
like the event you started with one out
of 36 right so that's why you've got
yeah it's almost double their big deal
okay